Make up is and always has been a big part
of the movies.
These days, however, an awful lot of the special
effects that make up aesthetically complex
characters are non-practical - generated,
for example, using sophisticated CGI.But there's
something a bit more charming about old school
make up.
If and when it's possible to make a character
look fantastic via the magic of make up artistry,
that should always be the first choice for
any production.There have been some amazing
transformations throughout movie history using
practical make up effects and this video will
look at some of the best.
Here are ten of the craziest movie make up
transformations you won't actually believe.
Heath Ledger in The Dark Knight
The late Heath Ledger gave an Oscar-winning
performance as Batman's arch-nemesis The Joker
in The Dark Knight - and his make up certainly
helped.
The remarkable thing about Ledger's make up
in this movie is that there really wasn't
much of it - it wasn't very "heavy" - but
Ledger was still totally unrecognisable and
mysterious under the face paint and scar prosthetics.
Costume designer Lindy Hemming came up with
the anarchical design, which took inspiration
from pop artists like Pete Doherty, Iggy Pop,
and Johnny Rotten.
It was made up of three pieces of stamped
silicone - a "new technology" at the time
- and took less than an hour for the movie's
make up artists to apply.
Jeff Goldblum in The Fly
1986's The Fly was a remake of the 1958 movie
of the same name and, as you would expect,
the make up effects were vastly improved on
the original.
Jeff Goldblum played the lead role of Seth
Brundle, who transformed into the hideous
"Brundlefly" when a common housefly joined
him in a teleportation pod of his own invention
and their bodies merged.
Chris Walas both designed and executed the
Academy Award-winning make up that conveyed
the transformation over seven different stages,
culminating in a terrifying final form that
was asymmetrical and deformed, looking almost
cancerous in nature.
Michael Keaton in Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice won the Academy Award for best
make up, as the effects created by the make
up team were fantastic throughout the movie,
but none were more iconic in appearance than
the titular character himself, who was played
by Michael Keaton.
Ve Neill, Steve LaPorte and Robert Short were
the make up geniuses behind the movie's fantastic
aesthetic, with Keaton's twisted and perverted
Beetlejuice made up to look like a disgusting
rotting corpse.
And yet somehow the character was actually
quite likeable?
Weird.
Linda Blair in The Exorcist
Linda Blair's make up in the terrifying horror
classic The Exorcist turned her from an innocent
and pretty young girl into a horrifying-looking
victim of demonic possession.
Blair's character, Regan MacNeil, was made
to look like the demon inside her was destroying
her body from within, as her face turned a
sickly shade of pale green and became covered
in painful-looking sores.
Dick Smith was the man behind the make up
for the movie, which also involved making
Max von Sydow's character, Father Lankester
Merrin, look 74 when the actor was only 44
at the time of filming.
Jim Carrey in How the Grinch Stole Christmas
How the Grinch Stole Christmas saw the wonderful
Jim Carrey transformed into Dr. Seuss' iconic
character, the grumpy titular Grinch.
Transformation into the green, furry, pig-nosed
miser was a real chore for the actor.
The prosthetic make-up took around eight hours
to apply by a team of make up artists - and
it also took around an hour to get out of.
Carrey deserves a medal for spending 92 days
wearing it, as he felt so horribly confined
and uncomfortable in the latex skin that he
needed counseling from a CIA agent, who taught
him torture-resistance techniques to deal
with the discomfort.
Ron Perlman in Hellboy/Hellboy II: The Golden
Army
Ron Perlman already has the gruff, square-jawed
look that made him perfect to play Hellboy,
but the make up that finished the job was
pretty damn great.
Matt Rose at Cinovation Studios was responsible
for the design and transformation, which gave
Perlman a red face, clipped horns, a big hammer-like
hand and left his eyelids as the only part
of his body that were visible.
Incidentally, in 2012, Perlman visited a sick
young boy named Zachary in full Hellboy make
up - and he looked every bit as cool as he
did in the movie itself.
In a way, he looked very similar to Tim Curry
as Darkness in Legend, who is also very worthy
of a mention on this list.
Charlize Theron in Monster
The incredibly beautiful Charlize Theron underwent
an unbelievable transformation into serial
killer Aileen Wuornos for 2003's brilliant
crime drama Monster.
Wuornos - a former prostitute - killed six
men, and Theron's resemblence to her was uncanny
by the time her make up was applied.
Theron put on 30lbs of weight, shaved her
eyebrows and wore both contact lenses and
prosthetic dentures to portray her, but it
was the work of make up artist Toni G that
really made the transformation so spectacular.
Theron's skin was aged and freckles were added.
Combined with an Oscar-worthy acting performance
from the actress, the transformation was complete.
Eric Stoltz in Mask
The make up Eric Stoltz wore in The Mask was
fantastic.
Portraying Roy L. "Rocky" Dennis, Stoltz's
make up augmented a performance that was already
both extremely heartfelt and, frankly, emotionally
draining.
The make up emphasised the devastating nature
of Dennis' condition - craniodiaphyseal dysplasia
- without exaggerating it in a crude or disrespectful
way.
Michael Westmore and Zoltan Elek were the
creative masterminds behind a transformation
that rendered Stoltz completely unrecognisable.
John Hurt in The Elephant Man
John Hurt portrayed Joseph Merrick AKA the
Elephant Man in the brilliant and moving 1980
movie of the same name, and the make up involved
was incredible - so incredible, in fact, that
it holds up nearly forty years later, in an
age when unbelievably realistic CGI is commonplace.
Make up artist Christopher Tucker designed
the look for Hurt's character - who suffered
from severe cranial deformities - from actual
casts of Merrick and it made such an impression
that the Academy decided to add a category
make up category to the Oscars, as protest
letters were sent to them for not giving The
Elephant Man an award for it.
Rebecca Romijn & Jennifer Lawrence in the
X-Men Movies
Both Rebecca Romijn and Jennifer Lawrence
have portrayed the shapeshifting mutant known
as Mystique AKA Raven Darkholme in the X-Men
franchise - and the transformation both actresses
underwent was pretty damn amazing.
Mystique's natural form is a beautiful blue
scaly work of art, and Romijn and Lawrence
had to each undergo around seven hours' worth
of make up being applied by fairly large teams
of make up artists, whilst half naked, to
become the character - and we think you'll
agree that both of them looked absolutely
awesome.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 craziest
movie make up transformations you won't believe.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other great movie make up transformations
impressed you?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.